[Musik]
eine Welle des Protests schwaabt durch
Deutschland eine Flut an Desinformation
geht durchs Netz mit dem sehr harten
Vorwurf das ZDF hätte dort ein Bild
manipuliert manipulierte Bilder
gekarperte Proteste von oben
orchestriert daneben steckt da aber
natürlich auch im Grunde eine Art
Verschwörungstheorie dahinter was die
Demos gegen Rechtsextremismus bewirken
können was an den Vorwürfen dran ist und
wer davon
profitiert es sind Bilder wie diese die
der AFD ihre Erzählung streitig machen
die Stimme des Volkes die Stimme der
Mehrheit zu
sein Demos für Demokratie und Vielfalt
gegen Rechtsextremismus und die
AFD gerade am Höhepunkt ihrer
Popularität jeder fünfte würde laut
Umfragen die AFD wählen doch warum gehen
gerade jetzt so viele auf die Straße ich
bin sehr sehr selten auf Demonstrationen
aber ich glaube das ist heute ein Punkt
wo man einfach mal dabei sein sollte und
zeigen sollte dass man auch gegen diese
Entwicklung in Deutschland ist ich habe
genug Freunde die nach den Regeln der
AFD halt abgeschoben werden würden was
die meisten auf die Straße treibt die
Enthüllungen der
rechercheattform Mitte Januar über ein
Geheimtreffen in Potzdam da haben sich
sowohl Vertreter der AFD unter anderem
der ehemalige persönliche Sekretär von
Alice
Weidel aber auch Vertreter der
werteunion mit Personen aus dem Umfeld
der identitären Bewegung getroffen der
bekannteste Kopf davon Martin selner und
dann waren noch einige Personen vor Ort
die eher im Hintergrund agieren aber die
eben durchaus finanzstark sind und
bereit dazu sind auch Aktivitäten
solcher Aktivisten zu
finanzieren Thema bei dem Geheimtreffen
nach korrektivberichten die Idee der
sogenannten Remigration Remigration also
die Rückführung von Menschen in diesem
Fall aus
Deutschland ist so eine Vokabel die
deswegen glaube ich ganz griffig ist und
strategisch wertvoll ist für die
identitären weil sie nicht ganz
eindeutig ist es geht es hier um die
Rückführung straffälliger Asylbewerber
oder Menschen mit einem unklaren
Aufenthaltsstatus oder geht es
tatsächlich um die Rückführung von
deutschen Staatsbürgern die allerdings
unter bestimmten ethnischen Kriterien
die die identitäre Bewegung sich
überlegt für sie keine richtigen
Deutschen sind sondern nur deutsche
zweiter Klasse die Enthüllungen zum
Geheimtreffen setzen in Deutschland
etwas in
Bewegung es kommt zu einigen der größten
Kundgebungen seit
Jahrzehnten plötzlich ist diese Woche zu
einer demonstrationswoche gegen
Rechtsextremismus geworden so gehen
jetzt auch viele auf die Straße und
zeigen Gesicht die Protestwelle gegen
rechten Extremismus sie t nicht ab im
Gegenteil sie erfasst offenbar immer
mehr Städte im ganzen Bundesgebiet Kiel
Kaufbeuren Bielefeld Braunschweig Bochum
Dortmund Erfurt Leipzig Kemnitz
Heidelberg München ein ganz anderes Bild
der Demos verbreiten in des alternativ
im Netz alles manipuliert alles
aufgebauscht alles nur
Fake die AFD geht in die Offensive
versucht Zweifel zu sehen drei Beispiele
von Desinformation und wie sie sich im
Netz wierlegen
lassen Beispiel 1 Thüringens AFD Chef
Björn höcke postet dieses Foto und
behauptet bestellte Massen demonstrieren
gegen die AFD wirft den Medien
Bildmanipulationen
vor das ist ein Bild der Demonstration
in Hamburg in der Hamburger Innenstadt
mit dem sehr harten Vorwurf dass ZDF
hätte dort ein Bild manipuliert und
hätte dort zusätzliche Menschen hinein
editiert die dort nicht auf der Straße
sondern im Wasser in der Alster stehen
würden die Erklärung für dieses Bild ist
keine Manipulation sondern einfach eine
Frage der Perspektive das Foto ist von
weiter unten aufgenommen worden
entsprechend sieht die Menschenmenge
dort größer aus und die die Alster
kleiner mit der Verbreitung von
Falschinformationen verfolgen die AFD
und parteinahe Akteure gleich mehrere
Strategien zum einen soll natürlich der
Protest als solcher klein geredet werden
daneben steckt da aber natürlich auch im
Grunde eine Art Verschwörungstheorie
dahinter nämlich dass die Regierung und
die Mensch die vermeintlichen
politischen elit
die die AFD ausgrenzen wollen dass die
mit den Medienvertretern unter einer
Decke
stecken viel Aufmerksamkeit im Netz
bekommt auch dieser Post Beispiel 2 ein
AFD Politiker macht den Vorwurf Bäume
würden im Januar grüne Blätter tragen
das Bild sei
manipuliert das ganze kann man aber auch
relativ einfach widerlegen wenn man sich
den Ort anguckt in Köln sieht man
nämlich d dort an der Stelle ein Lokal
ist und an diesem Lokal das ist jetzt
auf Google Maps in diesem Lokal ist eine
Außenbeleuchtung in grüner Farbe und das
ist eine sehr nahliegende Erklärung für
die grüne Farbe in diesem Bild keine ai
Manipulation sondern einfach eine
Außenbeleuchtung eines Lokals nicht alle
falsche Informationen kommen aus der
Ecke der AFD das zeigt Beispiel 3 ein
Video von einem Licht me in Berlin
gepostet vom Zentrum für politische
Schönheit es scheint als würden
ztausende vor dem Reichstag singen doch
es stellt sich heraus der Ton ist nicht
der original
sound die SPD Bundestagsfraktion ist der
Urheber des Videos die haben das zuerst
auf tiktok gepostet die haben den Sound
drunter gelegt und das Zentrum für
politische Schönheit hat sich das dann
geschnappt und einfach selber gepostet
auf Instagram allerdings hat da jeder
Hinweis gefehlt dass die Musik nicht zum
tatsächlichen Video gehört die SPD hatte
das Video mit einem transparenzinweis
Versehen aber warum verwendet sie
überhaupt ein anderes Audio Sounds und
Musik aus anderen Videos zu nehmen und
unter das eigene Video drunter zu
schneiden die Fraktion sieht da kein
Problem bei weil es eben gängige Praxis
ist und auch weil das Lied das man hört
bei der Demo gesungen wurde tatsächlich
nur eben nicht so laut und von anderen
Leuten der Schaden ist trotzdem groß das
Video millionenmal aufgerufen und
tausendfach geteilt liefert Akteuren die
Fake News über die Demos verbreiten eine
Angriffsfläche die nehmen solche
Beispiele natürlich als gefundenes
Fressen um die eigenen Positionen
bestärken zu können und darauf hinweisen
zu können ah hier sieht man jetzt die
manipulieren das Audio um das besser
klingen zu lassen also daher kann das
schon eben Munition sein zur Verbreitung
von von von weiteren
Falschinformationen ein weiterer Vorwurf
gegen Demonstrationen wie die hier in
München sie seien von linksextremen
gekarpert schon im Vorfeld der Münchner
Kundgebung hatte freie wählerchef Hubert
eiwanger kritisiert man bekämpft ein
extrem nicht mit dem anderen Extrem was
ist da
dran angestoßen hat die Großdemo
gemeinsam gegen Rechts l uali von
Fridays for future seine
Motivation gleichgültigkeit ist eins der
gefährlichsten politischen Mittel weil
wenn der Großteil nichts tut dann kann
eine ganz kleine Minderheit ihren Willen
durchdrücken und das darf nicht in
unserer Demokratie passieren und genau
deshalb ist Demokratie mehr als einmal
alle vier Jahre ein Kreuz auf den Zettel
zu setzen seinem Aufruf schließen sich
über 250 Organisationen und laut Polizei
mehr als 100.000 Menschen an auf der
Bühne wird aber nicht nur Stimmung gegen
die AFD gemacht sondern auch gegen die
ampelregierung und die
Union erst am Donnerstag hat die Ampel
beschlossen die serettung zu krimin
realisieren wie findet ihr
das und schön dass auch die CSU heute
hier aufrufen will wir sind sehr
gespannt auf Ihre Brandmauer nach rechts
die sie damit scheinbar sein möchte
Vertreter der angesprochenen CSU haben
es sich trotz Kritik nicht nehmen lassen
an der Demo teilzunehmen mit gemischten
Gefühlen zunächst einmal bin ich
unglaublich stolz dass 150 200000 250
000 Menschen hergekommen sind um klar zu
sagen nein zu Rassismus Nein zu
Rechtsextremismus Nein zu Nazis und wir
stehen auf gegen demokratiefeinde das
macht mich wirklich stolz auf der
anderen Seite hat sich der Veranstalter
als ungeeignet erwiesen weil er sich
nicht klar ausschließlich gegen die AFD
und Rechtsextremismus gewandt hat
sondern sogar gegen die Bundesregierung
und die demokratische Opposition das
finde ich
inakzeptabel auch teilnehmende Vereine
wie München ist Bund distanzieren sich
von manchen Äußerungen auf der Demo die
Veranstalter von Friday for future
Räumen ein es habe Momente auf der Demo
gegeben in denen der Tonfall verrutscht
sei prinzipiell ist es aber natürlich
auch so dass es bei einem Rechtsruck ja
nicht nur drum geht dass die AFD als
Partei den verursacht sondern auch
andere Parteien dazu beitragen durch
ihre Rhetorik indem sie Sachen
salanfähig machen das heißt es gilt auch
die in die Verantwortung zu nehmen
Münchens Oberbürgermeister will für
künftige Aktionen ein neues Bündnis
schmieden ein buntes
nicht nur aus Vereinen und
Organisationen sondern auch aus
Parteien wir müssen schauen dass Politik
und Zivilgesellschaft zusammenwachsen in
dem Bereich und dann werden wir sehen
wie wir gemeinsam weiter vorgehen durch
Experten sehen das wertvolle der
Proteste gerade darin dass sie von der
Zivilgesellschaft ausgehen das waren
eben nicht Parteien die das organisiert
haben das kam aus der Gesellschaft
selbst das ist die Antwort von
Mitbürgern und die zählt in einer
solchen Situation tatsächlich mehr weil
sie nicht von oben kommt wie geht es
weiter mit den Protesten und bringt es
überhaupt was auf die Straße zu
gehen ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen
dass es vor allen Dingen da zu einer
stärkeren Mobilisierung kommt und eben
viele Menschen so bisschen aus dem dem
dem wachschlaf herausgerissen wurden
diese Bedrohung durch die
AFD ernster nehmen die auch die die Art
und Weise wie rechts Konzepte in den
Mainstream sickern ernster nehmen es
zeigt eben dass die Zivilgesellschaft
deutlich Stärke ist als wir es manchmal
wahrnehmen sie kommt immer dann ins
Spiel wenn riskante Situation für die
Demokratie auftreten und das ist ein
gutes
Zeichen ein Zeichen dass die
Zivilgesellschaft laut wird und die
Brandmauer plötzlich auf Deutschlands
Straßen steht
[Musik]